WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
WHEN THE STORY BROKE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON WAS FIRED, TRUMP
HATING POLITICOS AND MEDIA TYPES
SEIZED ON THE DEPARTURE AS MORE
EVIDENCE THAT THE DOORS ARE
COMING OFF THE WHITE HOUSE.
SPEAK OF THE MOST CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT WE'VE SEEN OF LATE
THAT WE HAVE A GOVERNING CRISIS.
>> DETECTED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF DISARRAY AND CHAOS.
>> NOBODY LAST LONG IN THE CHAOS
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> IT PROJECTS INSTABILITY TO
ALLIES AND ADVERSARIES.
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH AND I HAVE
HEARD FROM A SENIOR DEMOCRATIC
FOREIGN POLICY MAVEN, IF YOU
WILL COME OF THE AMOUNT OF
DYSFUNCTION IN THE FOREIGN
POLICY APPARATUS.
>> Laura: POLICY MAVEN, IF YOU
WILL?
AS USUAL, THE LEMMINGS ARE
TOTALLY JUMPING OFF THE LEDGE
TOGETHER, OKAY?
HERE'S WHAT I LEARNED WHEN I WAS
A 22-YEAR-OLD WHITE HOUSE
STAFFER.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LEARNED?
YOU WORK AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU ACCEPT ANY POSITION IN
ANY ADMINISTRATION, YOUR JOB IS
TO PURSUE THE GOALS OF THE
PRESIDENT, NOT YOUR OWN.
YOUR JOB IS TO FIND WAYS TO
ACCOMPLISH HIS PRIORITIES, NOT
YOUR OWN.
YOUR JOB IS TO ADVOCATE HIS
WORLDVIEW, NOT YOUR OWN.
STICK WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
ENTITLED TO THE STAFF THAT HE
WANTS.
AT ANY MOMENT, STAFF PERSON WHO
WORKS DIRECTLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND HE SHOULD HAVE PEOPLE WHO HE
TRUSTS IN VALUE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS POMPEO
TODAY.
I HAVE KNOWN JOHN BOLTON FOR
DECADES.
HE'S APPEARED ON THE SHOW MANY
TIMES.
WE OBVIOUSLY REALLY LIKE HIM AND
RESPECT HIM VERY MUCH.
BUT HIS POSITION AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, LET'S ALL BE
HONEST, IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO
BE A COMPLICATED FIT.
REMEMBER, BOLTON OF COURSEWORK
FOR GEORGE W. BUSH IN ONE
POSITION AS U.N. AMBASSADOR AND
IN SOME AREAS, HE IS CLOSER TO
THE INTERVENTIONIST WING OF THE
G.O.P. THEN HE IS TO TRUMP
AMERICA FIRST VIEW.
I STILL REMEMBER WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS USED TO AGREE WITH
BEING A LESS INTERVENTIONIST
POWER.
BUT THEN TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME TOOK HOLD AND THEY
BECAME WALKING CONTRADICTIONS OF
THEMSELVES.
HERE'S WHAT DEMOCRAT SOUNDED
LIKE WHEN BOLTON WAS APPOINTED.
>> JOHN BOLTON DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE WAS BEING HIRED FOR.
LET ALONE NOT KNOWING THAT HE
WAS BEING HIRED.
JOHN BOLTON IS A DANGEROUS MAN.
>> JOHN BOLTON I THINK IS A
DISASTROUS PICK.
TO BE IT COMES TO JOHN BOLTON,
OF CONGRESS DOES NOT WANT TO GO
TO WAR, NOW IT'S TIME TO PUT
RESTRAINTS ON THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: HERE IS WHAT THEY
SOUND LIKE NOW.
>> ON A COUPLE KEY ISSUES, THIS
FAILED IDEA FOR A SUMMATIVE
CAMP DAVID IN THESE COLOSSAL
FAILURES WITH NORTH KOREA,
BOLTON WAS RIGHT.
>> NEEDED NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR WHO WAS WILLING TO GIVE
YOUR ALTERNATIVE VIEWS.
>> JOHN BOLTON WILL LAND ON HIS
FEET.
HE ALSO HAS A KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
CERTAIN WAYS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS,
INTERNATIONAL ACTIONS.
>> Laura: THAT COULD BE MY
FAVORITE THEN AND NOW EVER BY
THE WAY.
EVEN NATE SILVER SAW THIS FOR
WHAT IT WAS, IN HIS TWEET SAYING
"ABM A SIMPLETON BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE YOU CRITICIZED BOLTON'S
HIRING, YOU PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
ALSO CRITICIZE HIS
FIRING."
MEDIA GOOFBALLS ARE FOCUSED ON
THE DISCREPANCY WHETHER BOLTON
WOULD QUIT OR WHETHER HE WAS
FIRED.
HE SAYS THE FARMER AND RELEASE
THIS TERSE RESIGNATION LETTER
DATED TODAY.
TRUMP SAID HE ASKED FOR THE
RESIGNATION, TRANSLATION FIRED
HIM LAST NIGHT.
WHO CARES WHICH IT WAS?
IT WAS LONG OVERDUE.
TRUMP'S ALLEGIANCE ISN'T ANY
PARTICULAR PROCESS OR ANY
PARTICULAR CABINET MEMBER BUT TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ELECTED HIM AND
TO THE COUNTRY AT LARGE.
HE IS A TRUE MAVERICK BECAUSE HE
CAME LIKE A FREIGHT TRAIN AT THE
OLD G.O.P. FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT THAT HAD GOTTEN US
BOGGED DOWN IN TWO COSTLY WARS
AS CHINA GREW BASICALLY
UNCHALLENGED.
TRUMP PROMISED TO BRING OUR
TROOPS HOME FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
YET AT THE MILITARY NATIONAL
SECURITY OFFICIALS HAVE MOSTLY
RESISTED HIM EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY ON THAT GOAL.
THIS FRUSTRATES THE PRESIDENT TO
NO END.
HE KNOWS MOST AMERICANS DON'T
JUST WANT OUR TROOPS BACK HOME
BUT THEY DON'T EVEN THINK THE
WARS IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN
WERE WORTH FIGHTING.
BUT THE OLD BUSH TEAM OF COURSE
THEY WON'T TAKE NO FOR AN
ANSWER.
DESPITE OBAMA'S ELECTION THEN,
TRUMP'S ELECTION, OF COURSE
OBAMA CAME IN AT 2008 AND THEN
TRUMP IN 2016 WHICH REPRESENTED
A BIPARTISAN AND TOTAL
REPUDIATION OF THE BUSH DOCTRIN
DOCTRINE.
>> HE LEFT OUR TROOPS IN EUROPE
FOR 45 YEARS UNTIL GERMANY
COULD UNIFY BETWEEN 1945 AND
1990.
WE ARE STILL THERE.
WE KEEP THE PEACE ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA SINCE 1953.
I KNOW AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF
SOME OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES BUT
FRANKLY THERE'S NOBODY BUT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA THAT
CAN DO THIS.
>> Laura: WE LOVE CONDI BUT
IT'S NOT 1945 OR 1953.
IT'S THE 21ST CENTURY.
TWO WARS THAT BEGAN POST 9/11,
THIS IS WHERE PUBLIC OPINION IS.
LOOK AT IT.
62% SAY IRAQ WASN'T WORTH
FIGHTING.
59% SAY AFGHANISTAN WASN'T WORTH
SO LOOK.
CONTRARY TO BEING A SIGN OF
CHAOS, THE BOLTON NEWS I THINK
SHOWS A COMMITMENT TO PRINCIPLE
AND EFFICIENCY.
ANYONE WHO CAN'T PRODUCE RESULTS
AND ANYONE WHO CAN'T GET ON
BOARD WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA SHOULDN'T BE INSIDE
WORKING TO OPPOSE HIM OR
UNDERMINE HIM.
H.R. MCMASTER WAS CANNED AFTER
SOME THOUGHT HE BUMBLED HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
TILLERSON WAS A COLOSSAL FAILURE
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
PRICE WAS FIRED AFTER MAKING NO
HEADWAY ON DRUG PRICES.
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WAS GONE WHEN
SHE COULDN'T MANAGE THE BORDER
CRISIS.
SESSIONS WERE SHOWN THE DOOR AT
DOJ AFTER MYRIAD MISTAKES
INCLUDING ONE THAT LED TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
GARY COHN QUIT WHEN HE LOST THE
DEBATE ON TARIFFS.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI.
HE WAS OUT AFTER TEN DAYS I WAS
PRESS SECRETARY WHEN IT BECAME
TOO MUCH MOCHE AND NOT A HALF
MAGA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IMPATIENT
FOR RESULTS AND HE'S GOING TO
CHANGE PERSONNEL AS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THEM.
I WILL TAKE THAT ANY DAY OVER
SOMEONE WHO CAVALIERLY COPES ON
THE STATUS QUO OR DOUBLES DOWN
ON FAILURE WITH A SWAGGER.
TRUMP'S FOREIGN POLICY IS BEST
DESCRIBED AS PRUDENT REALISM.
HE BELIEVES THAT GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THE U.S. ECONOMY NOW
REPRESENTS ABOUT 20 TO 25% OF
THE GLOBAL GDP, WE NEED TO
MAXIMIZE OUR LEVERAGE WISELY.
TRUMP ACTUALLY CONSIDERS HOW
MUCH MILITARY MISSIONS COST.
COST OUR TAXPAYERS THEIR
HARD-EARNED MONEY.
AND WHETHER THEY MAKE OUR LIFE
HERE BETTER AND SAFER AT HOME.
AGAIN, THE BUSHES, VERY
PATRIOTIC PEOPLE AND WE HONOR
THEIR SERVICE IN GOVERNMENT BUT
THEY DIDN'T SPEND A LOT OF TIME
WORRYING ABOUT THOSE DETAILS.
SO LOOKING BACK ON IT, IS THAT
APPROACH MORE MORAL THAN TRUMP'S
WHEN OUR CITIZENS DRIVE ON ROADS
AND BRIDGES THAT ARE FALLING
APART?
MOST VOTERS THINK WE SHOULD FIX
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR AIRPORTS
BEFORE WE TRY TO FIX SYRIA'S.
RIGHT NOW, TRUMP HAS A STELLAR
TEAM IN PLACE.
JUST TO NAME A FEW, SECRETARY OF
STATE POMPEO, ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR, BOB LIGHTHIZER A
TRADE, NEVER BEEN A TRADE REP
BETTER THAN HE.
STEVE MINASIAN AT TREASURY.
ALEX LAZAR AT HHS, PHENOMENAL.
MARK ESPER, ACTING SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, TERRIFIC.
THEY'LL UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE IS
TO ADVANCE THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA.
THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS.
SURE, YOU OFFER YOUR ADVICE AND
SOMETIMES YOU DEBATE.
THE PRESIDENT IS FINE WITH THAT,
BUT THEN YOU GET ON BOARD WITH
WHATEVER HE DECIDES, NOT YOUR
DECISION.